What's up guys? We are back. And in this video today, we're modifying an idea we tried out in a previous project video.
It's called the car hero key box. You might remember from that video,
we took a child's vitamin container and modified it to become a secret hiding place for car keys.
Which is extremely strong and could be hidden out of sight and with three young kids running around,
I can't tell you how many times that actually saved me for being locked out of the vehicle.
When I released that video, I noticed the comments filled up with concerns from people mentioning that today's cars use
transponders instead of keys. And that is a legitimate concern, so the purpose of this video today is to put the
transponder to the test. Now for anyone who is unfamiliar,
let's talk about what a transponder is.  The technology in these things allows your car to recognize when you are actually inside it. So rather
than having to start your car with the car keys, now it's just a simple push of a button
Now you might remember I did a video for Castro motor oil, which required me to buy a new vehicle.
When I bought this new vehicle here, it came with the transponder,
so it's a perfect opportunity to put this to the test. This right here is my new car hero key box,
you can see there's one small modification from the original version. The container is a lot smaller. The reason is that
children's vitamins were the cheapest thing I could find before, and they still cost four or five dollars.
But seasonings like this, only cost about a buck. And the mouth of the container is just wide enough to accept the key fob.
Now the main concern I saw raised from people in the comments, was if you had a transponder stuck to the bottom of your vehicle,
would it be in close enough range that a stranger could hop in, start your car and drive away?
The purpose of this video is to find out. Okay guys, we're ready for the test. And for this I want to try two
experiments. For the first experiment we're going to take this inside the car with us and see if we can get the vehicle to start.
For test number two, we're going to mount this up underneath the vehicle in the hiding place we intended to go. And we'll see if
that makes any difference
So I'm back in my car right now, and I do not have my transponder with me. So theoretically my car should not start.
Yeah, and you can see right there,
it says the key is not detected. Now if this transponder is anywhere in the car,
it will be picked up.
But you can see just holding it two feet out,
the key is not detected by the vehicle here. If I bring it within about a foot,
then the car recognizes it. So inside the vehicle, apparently it will work.
Now, these neodymium magnets aren't extremely strong. And the underside of your vehicle is mostly made of steel.
So you can virtually pick any nook and cranny underneath your vehicle to stick this to,
and it's not coming off.
Beautiful. All right guys, here's the moment of truth. Our key box has been hidden underneath the vehicle,
so if we press the button, what's going to happen?
It says the key is still not detected. Which means the vehicle doesn't recognize the transponder anywhere.
This is good news, because it means you can carry a spare transponder underneath your vehicle, and your vehicle won't even know it's there.
I tried putting my car hero key box on the windshield and the roof of the vehicle, and the car still started.
But in the wheel wells, and underneath the vehicle, it was not recognized. So based on these experiments here today guys,
I would say that a spare transponder hidden in the car hero key box underneath your vehicle,
is a pretty safe way to go. But just remember that every car is a little bit different,
so go ahead and double check that this works with yours as well.
Thanks for joining me for this experiment guys. I'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then.
I am today.
Is that right? (Doctor: Not every day but close) No kidding really?
(Doctor: I recognized you from there, that's pretty good.) For real? Check this out! Right here! Just got recognized! Doctor's in the house!
*Chuckle* Doctor: Random happens.
Hey guys! Quick reminder that limited time King of Random T-Shirts are now on sale.
Click the link at the top of the description, or visit randomgear.com. See you there.